notre audition qui est la dernière de
l'après-midi puisque nous venons
successivement
d'auditionner Lana et la Caisse des
dépôts est conciliation et donc cette
dernière audition qui concerne donc
l'ADEME donc monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur merci de vous être
prêté à cette convocation en forme de
cas demande de participation à cette
audition donc monsieur le Président vous
exercez depuis décembre 2022 la
présidence de l'Agence de
l'environnement et de la maîtrise de
l'énergie la dame qui est je le rappelle
à l'établissement public industriel et
commercial pardon participant à la
construction des politiques nationales
locales et locales de transition
écologique mais vous êtes également
maire de Charleville-Mézières et
président Dardenne métropole depuis 2014
et vous y êtes et vous étiez jusqu'à
votre nomination à l'ADEME
vice-président de la région Grand Est
votre audition doit nous permettre d'une
part de mieux comprendre les missions
les objectifs et le bilan de l'ADEME en
tant qu'acteur de la politique de
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
l'ADEME qui est l'agence de la
transition écologique est-elle selon
vous suffisamment associé au politique
de rénovation énergétique le partage des
responsabilités entre avec Lana vous
semble-t-il suffisamment clair ou selon
vous doit-il encore évoluer d'autre part
cette audition de nous permettre
d'examiner les préconisations effectuées
par votre agence dans différents
rapports au titre de sa mission
d'animation de la recherche dans le
domaine de la transition écologique
votre agence a ainsi publié en janvier
2021 un rapport sur la rénovation
performante dans cette publication était
détaillée les inconvénients d'une
rénovation partielle pour la performance
énergétique bâtiment mais aussi pour le
confort de l'habitant deux ans après le
gouvernement a-t-il selon vous pris en
compte les conclusions de cette étude
les politiques publiques de rénovation
énergétique
favorise-t-elle suffisamment les
rénovations globales le dispositif mon
accompagnateur rénove permettra-t-il
selon vous d'encourager les ménages à
généraliser les rénovations globales à
cet égard certains ont plaidé devant
nous pour un guichet unique d'autres
pour préserver au contraire la diversité
des accueils mais unifiée le back-office
en ayant un dossier et une offre unique
pour les ménages avez-vous une opinion à
ce sujet par ailleurs avec votre regard
des local comment percevez-vous ce
dispositif d'accompagnement et
l'association des collectivités à la
rénovation énergétique avec votre
expérience de mère de président de
communauté d'agglomération et d'élus
régionales quel est selon vous le
meilleur niveau d'intervention plus
récemment en 2022 l'ADEME avait publié
un rapport sur le financement de la
rénovation énergétique performante des
logements vous y faites de très
nombreuses propositions pour les
logements individuels mais aussi pour
les copropriétés afin de répondre au
déficit de financement actuel
pourriez-vous nous indiquer les
propositions qui vous semblent les plus
urgentes pour améliorer le financement
des travaux de rénovation avant de vous
laisser la parole pour répondre à ses
premières questions et pour un propos
introductif d'une vingtaine de minutes
me revient de vous indiquer que cette
audition est diffusée en direct et en
différé sur le site internet du Sénat et
qu'un compte-rendu sera publié je dois
également vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des prennent
peines prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de trois ans à 5 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros à
100000 euros d'amende je vous invite
donc monsieur le Président Monsieur le
directeur a prêté serment de dire toute
la vérité rien que la vérité a levé la
main droite et à dire je le jure
je vous en remercie donc nous vous
laissons la parole et ensuite dans notre
rapporteur que nos collègues qui
assistent également à l'audition
pourront vous poser un certain nombre de
questions complémentaires merci beaucoup
alors madame la Présidente sur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs membres
de la commission d'enquête d'abord je
voulais vous remercier de cette
invitation que vous nous faites de venir
évoquer un sujet qui est un sujet
absolument fondamental pour la réussite
de des grands objectifs que ces données
notre pays à savoir celui notamment de
la neutralité carbone à l'horizon 2050
c'est vraiment sur ce sur cette base là
que la DM travaille vous savez l'ADEM
aura l'occasion d'y revenir un certain
nombre de politiques d'accompagnement de
soutien à destination des aujourd'hui
des entreprises et des collectivités et
puis
un rôle d'information à l'égard des du
grand public mais là aussi depuis
maintenant de très nombreuses années un
exercice de prospective consistant à
essayer de d'offrir au débat public mais
singulièrement aux assemblées au
parlementaires de notre pays des
trajectoires
permettant d'atteindre les grands
objectifs que nous donnons et là celui
de la neutralité carbone à l'horizon
2050 et vous savez conditions
conditionne notre le respect notre
engagement de notre signature et
signature de notre pays à l'accord de
Paris et donc est un engagement
extrêmement important nous avons évalué
plusieurs plusieurs scénarios ou les
services et les ingénieurs de l'ADEME
ont fait varier la sobriété énergétique
et puis d'autres les solutions concrètes
permettant d'atteindre cette neutralité
carbone et dans tous les cas et bien ce
que ce que nous constatons c'est le rôle
central de la rénovation énergétique à
opérer sur les bâtiments de notre pays
alors à la fois le logement mais aussi
tout le bâtiment d'activité tertiaires
c'est c'est cette rénovation elle est
incontournable et
on a chiffré à
lors de l'ordre de 700 000 700 000
pardon le nombre de rénovations qu'ils
doivent être réalisés chaque année avec
une référence en termes de qualité de la
rénovation c'est ça qui est extrêmement
important c'est que il s'agit de 700 000
rénovations de niveau de et de type BBC
visant à amener je parle sur le contrôle
de josecker qui connaît tout cela
infiniment mieux que moi mais amené les
logements à une consommation moyenne de
80 kWh par mètre carré par an c'est ça
la référence du BBC là où pour donner un
ordre d'idée on est plutôt aujourd'hui
autour de 200 kWh par mètre carré par an
en moyenne sur le parc au moins sur le
logement même probablement un peu plus
si on a
le tertiaire peut-être en tout cas on
doit diviser par 3 pour faire court à
peu près la consommation par mètre carré
par an pour atteindre effectivement
c'est ces niveaux qui sont ceux du BBC
donc 700 000 rénovations BBC par an
c'est ça l'objectif la trajectoire
alors on doit bien constater qu'il reste
un peu de chemin à parcourir puisque
aujourd'hui et on en discutait en venant
parce que c'est cette question est
l'anime un peu toute la communauté des
gens qui travaillent sur la rénovation
et énergétique on pense qu'on se situe
entre 40 et 60 000 rénovations BBC par
an l'impression n'est pas lié au fait au
flou sur le sur le concept c'est juste
que il y a des rénovations dont on sait
qu'elles correspondent à ce niveau là et
puis d'autres qui sont qui sont faites
et qui est forcément ne vont pas
chercher le label BBC alors qu'on pense
le ferait elle pourrait le mériter en
partie donc voilà entre 40 et 60 000 par
an
vis-à-vis de ou de 700 000 rénovations
annuelles donc on a une rénovation
énergétique et un sujet central et sur
lequel nous avons encore de grands
progrès à faire pour nous mettre
vraiment pleinement sur le sur la
trajectoire alors le second message que
je voudrais insister en préambule je me
suis donné que 5 donc je vous rassure ce
sera le propos liminaire ne se rend pas
trop long mais c'est que on a vraiment
le besoin
d'aligner l'ensemble des instruments de
la politique publique visant à la
rénovation énergétique de l'aligner sur
justement cette question de la
performance PVC c'est vraiment ça qui
pour les équipes de l'ADEME apparaît
apparaît centrale c'est que on se donne
ce cap là et donc il faut que le BBC
soit plus présent dans dans tous nos
messages de communication et qu'on fixe
ainsi vraiment c'est quelle ambition il
ne s'agit pas de rénover simplement de
manière énergétique ou thermique les
logements sans référence
il faut le faire avec cet objectif à
terme de en fait le l'objectif des 700
000 il est calé sur l'idée que en 2050
il faudrait que 90% du parc de logement
et cette performance BBC donc on a
on souhaite et on dans nos
communications on s'efforce de faire de
faire connaître et puis dans d'autres
travaux de faire connaître justement
c'est le fait que cette référence est
importante alors pour y parvenir c'est
complexe et ça nécessite absolument un
accompagnement et c'est là dessus qu'il
y a eu la des évolutions et que
récemment on a depuis quelques années
quand là encore dans les échanges que
j'avais avec José
quelques heures on constatait que il y a
fut un tout un temps où la question de
l'accompagnement à la rénovation
énergétique était pas considérée comme
une politique publique en tant que toi
en tant que c'était certains le faisait
il y a eu quelques précurseurs dans les
collectivités dans certains services de
l'État mais
l'idée de dire il faut un service public
de l'accompagnement à la rénovation
énergétique c'est une vraie innovation
qui n'a qui date de quelques années quoi
c'est 2018
la première apparition du conte du terme
je crois c'est 2015-2015 alors pardon
mais donc
et donc et donc on a aujourd'hui un
dispositif d'accompagnement alors pour
toujours le effectivement tout est
toujours perfectible mais ça constituait
enfin la mise en place de services
publics d'accompagnement à la rénovation
énergétique et constitue un vrai un vrai
plus vrai une vraie avancée et donc
c'est ainsi et pas simplement sur la
mobilisation de financement qui est
importante mais un socle il y a des
aides qui sont à porter au ménage on
aura peut-être l'occasion de revenir sur
la question de Quantum de ce qui doit
être public investissement privé enfin
ce sujet-là est naturellement encore
débattu pas complètement tranché
d'ailleurs à mon sens mais donc il y a
des aides publiques mais au-delà de ces
publics il faut vraiment qu'on fixe
l'ambition et qu'on est comme
aujourd'hui on s'y est force un
dispositif d'accompagnement des ménages
parce que cette rénovation énergétique
ambitieuse ne veut pas de soi et et
pas faire le savon moi qui suis très peu
bricoleur mais en fait cumulent une
succession de gestes c'est pas
simplement un geste unique dans le dans
la dans le logement ou dans le tertiaire
qui peut permettre d'atteindre
généralement cette cette performance il
faut cumuler plusieurs gestes de la part
donc des artisans des entreprises qui
travaillent
troisième message les
les aides financières donc je lisais pas
pas sur son nécessaire et utiles mais
elles ne sont clairement pas le seul
outil à disposition des pouvoirs publics
elles doivent être orientées vers la
performance donc là ce qu'on
constate c'est qu'on a aujourd'hui
dispositif ma prime rénov on a des C2S
et
la préconisation de l'ADEME c'est
qu'effectivement le ces outils là soient
le plus tourner possible vers la
performance atteint notamment celle de
rendre BBC les les bâtiments on pourrait
se dire que dans les dans les
dispositifs finalement qui sont à
disposition il y a aussi l'outil
réglementaire et que on envoie le début
de l'application puisque sur les
passoires thermiques les catégories FSG
le fait d'interdire la mise à la
location via un moment donné compléter
dispositif de rénovation qui aide c'est
donc c'est pas simplement d'inciter
d'avoir une politique incitative mais il
faut aussi sur
enfin en tout cas nous pensons que c'est
cohérent et que c'est efficace de
parfois d'utiliser l'arme réglementaire
pour
interdire la mise à la location et
provoquer donc des rénovations
le pari qui est fait de ces logements
les plus énergivores
on a quatrième message qui est sur le
dimensionnement de la politique de
rénovation aujourd'hui il se pratique
des rénovations dans le bâti d'or c'est
déjà pour un montant de travaux qui
voisine les 20 milliards d'euros et donc
on a un premier sujet que c'est ces
montants de rénovation qui sont investis
dans le bâtiment et qui souvent ont pour
finalité davantage de confort remettre
au goût du jour mais s'accompagne
systématiquement enfin le plus souvent
possible en tout cas d'une rénovation
énergétique et puis en fait pour pour
être cohérent avec les objectifs de
700000 euros l'idée c'est d'oublier par
deux le montant de ces investissements
donc de passer plutôt de l'ordre de 40
milliards d'euros d'investissement
chaque année donc
résolument orienté vers la rénovation
thermique des logements et du bâtiments
avec cette objective
BBC le cinquième et dernier message
peut-être l'iminaires c'est pour
souligner que il faut je crois que nous
ayons nous pensions collectivement cette
politique de rénovation comme ce qu'elle
est c'est à dire le chantier du siècle
pour notre pays c'est vraiment quand on
regarde l'ampleur de ce qu'il y a à
réaliser je crois une expression qui
n'est pas qui n'est pas galvaudée et qui
a des conséquences économiques
extrêmement fortes en amont on a
la formation des
entreprises de l'apparition probablement
même aussi nous pensons de de nouveaux
métiers finalement d'ensemble liés et de
gens capables dans le dans le logement à
la fois de réaliser ou de faire réaliser
les travaux avec le niveau de
performance attendue de pourquoi pas
dans certains cas être capable par le
tiers financement de financer ces
travaux et de s'engager ensuite sur le
la teinte de la performance en
énergétique donc on a vraiment
défense cette idée de a besoin d'un
ensemble billet et ça ça correspond
quand même surtout pour le logement des
particuliers sur sur des missions qui
n'existent pas pas encore ou très peu
aujourd'hui et qu'il va falloir
absolument développer
ça s'accompagne bien évidemment je c'est
évident mais c'est utile de le rappeler
sur le fait que on a vraiment besoin de
former davantage de de d'artisans et
compagnons du bâtiment dans les
entreprises justement à ces gestes et à
la performance qui est attendue et là et
donc on a vraiment l'émergence possible
d'une filière
dans les savoir-faire et d'une filière
aussi dans les matériaux puisque il y a
derrière des matériaux et notamment un
certain de de matériaux nouveaux ou
ou le retour de certains matériaux
d'ailleurs on pourrait même formuler
ainsi puisque
la bio économie peut permettre de
d'apporter de créer cette dématériaux
nouveaux utilisés pour procéder à la
rénovation thermique donc on est
vraiment dans la je crois le une
obligation qui nous est faite de
concevoir la politique de rénovation à
énergétique comme une
devant être soutenue par une filière
dont les éléments sont très largement
encore aujourd'hui à inventer à mettre
en place et à structurer alors quel est
le rôle de pour terminer quel est le
rôle de l'ADEME dans cette dans cette
rénovation énergétique et bien l'ADEME
je le disais effectivement à cette
mission d'éclairer l'avenir d'éclairer
les choix
en laissant ensuite aussi la
représentation nationale et le
gouvernement faire les choix puisque la
définition de la trajectoire ce qu'on
appellera la planification écologique
ici pour faire court ça ça ne relève pas
de l'ADEME nous on est là pour éclairer
les choix montrer les cohérences
et donc on travaille il y a beaucoup des
sujets que qui ont été évoqués jusqu'à
présent sur lesquels nous travaillons
encore de manière très très active parce
qu'on considère que notamment sur le
financement dans l'occasion d'y revenir
mais on n'a pas encore probablement
trouvé les bons produits la bonne
manière de prendre ce sujet je crois
qu'il faut le faux pouvoir le constater
avec avec lucidité et donc on travaille
à porter des éléments des analyses qui
vont qui peuvent permettre de prendre
les bons choix positionner une politique
de rénovation énergétique au bon niveau
d'ambition et avec les bons
accompagnements économiques et puis nous
avons de manière plus plus concrète dans
l'accompagnement
et à concevoir le service d'aide à la
rénovation énergétique et et
aujourd'hui on a une transition qui
s'effectue avec l'Agence nationale de
l'habitat sur ce sujet et toujours un
rôle extrêmement important des
collectivités dans la mise en œuvre de
cette de cette politique et s'agissant
je voudrais surtout pas qu'on les oublie
parce que c'est c'est
négatif que nous on appelle éco énergie
tertiaire
découle des décréteriaires c'est donc
sur tout le bâtiment
l'ADEME tient la comptabilité
déclaration donc c'est ce qu'on appelle
le dispositif opéra et donc à aussi au
niveau de chacun de ces territoires ou
les engagé au côté des collectivités et
bien le rôle d'apporter de l'ingénierie
de l'expertise auprès des collectivités
pour les aider à concevoir justement des
politiques cette fois-ci locales
tendance plutôt pardon de l'expression
mais bottom up qui qui correspondent aux
grands objectifs de notre pays voilà
finalement un peu les à la fois le
paysage général et comment la dame se
situe dans ce cadre là
alors vous m'avez posé un certain nombre
de questions je peux me permettre de
revenir plus plus précisément j'en ai
noté quelques-unes et si j'en ai oublié
je vous remercie d'avance de me les
rappeler
est-ce que je considère nous considérons
que l'agence est suffisamment associée
on va pouvoir dire qu'on est au cœur de
des réflexions sur ce sujet que
l'indiqué tout de suite sur le sur le
service de d'aide à la rénovation
énergétique nous sommes en liaison
constante avec Lana et avec ses
dirigeants et c'est une demande
effectivement
relève d'un arbitrage rendu par le
gouvernement que que nous mettons en
œuvre mais nous sommes aussi très
régulièrement le pôle d'expertise que
constitue Lana est très régulièrement
consultée sur la question de DPE sur les
questions de labellisation
des travaux à réaliser par par les
professionnels du bâtiment c'est aussi
que ce que les travaux que nous
réalisons sur sur le financement
lui est attendu avec intérêt par par
l'administration centrale enfin je crois
vraiment pouvoir dire oui que sur ce sur
cette question
l'ADEME et aujourd'hui consultée et
dispose d'une expertise que les que les
pouvoirs publics utilisent et
donc on a effectivement beaucoup insisté
et je laisserai je vous ai précisé s'il
le peut se concept mais de rénovation
performante en 2021 parce que comme je
l'indiquais tout à l'heure c'est
vraiment la combinaison de différents
gestes qui fait que la rénovation est
performante ou il ne l'est pas et
rénover son logement c'est ça peut être
c'est une affaire d'énergie ça peut être
une affaire aussi de confort c'est une
affaire de financement et puis ça n'est
pas sans inconvénient pour pour celui
qui rénove et les aspects de confort
évident d'être dans un logement en cours
de rénovation ou ou d'y entrer quand
après rénovation sont conditionne
énormément le travail à réaliser et donc
on a point de vue en tout cas peu
d'occasions finalement de faire ces
rénovations complètes
pense nous que que c'est autour des des
mutations qu'il faudrait arriver à
concentrer ce type d'approche alors ça
ouvre la porte à un sujet à une
discussion intéressante sur obligation
incitation et probablement l'une puis
puis peut-être un jour l'autre en tout
cas il faut donner de la perspective
mais il est difficile d'imaginer de
demander à des gens occupants leur
logement de le rénover de manière
énergétique Sat représente en
multipliant les gestes qui font toucher
la toiture les murs les différentes
huisseries et l'ensemble du du bâti tout
ça est assez difficile et un peu
illusoire donc comme on a peu
d'occasions et bien il faut que les
occasions soient les bonnes et qu'on
soit de la rénovation le plus possible
performante et donc qui qui cumulent les
gestes à réaliser alors est-ce que
est-ce que nous sommes là encore sur la
trajectoire les choses progressent c'est
vrai on a vu ces dernières années une
progression du nombre de de rénovations
de type BBC mais effectivement je le
disais l'indiqué tout à l'heure encore
sur un niveau qui laisse quelques
marches de progrès pour atteindre les
700 000 rénovations annuelles BBC dont
nous avons besoin donc je crois que
ce travail là de
et il faut le remettre sur cet ouvrage
sur le sur le métier pour peut-être se
poser la question de qui peut faire ce
type de rénovation performante comment
on voit ce que disait tout à l'heure
comment est-ce qu'on peut essayer
d'accompagner d'avoir des garanties de
performances au bout du compte parce que
c'est aussi ça qui permet plus
facilement le financement des des qui
peut permettre plus facilement le
financement des opérations à quel moment
on les fait à quel moment on met le
petit coup d'épaule qu'il faudrait ou
l'incitation ou l'encouragement pour que
les rénovations se fassent
il reste aujourd'hui pas mal de pas mal
de sujets à trancher
est-ce qu'on a je crois que j'ai une
question sur le guichet unique alors
le guichet unique des aides
pour l'État qu'il y a un outil important
en l'occurrence ma prime rénov ça paraît
ça paraît
aller dans ce sens là qui visible
après des guichets uniques
si cette au prix d'une perte de
notamment sur l'accompagnement d'une
perte d'accompagnement pour le coup de
de
personnes mobilisées mobilisables pour
accompagner les citoyens je crois pas
que ce soit que ça puisse être désirable
on a mis en place un service il y a
encore
à côté de ce service d'aide à la
rénovation énergétique un certain nombre
d'autres initiatives qui qui existent
des associations qui se donnent cet
objectif parfois d'autres niveaux de
collectivité qui ont conservé bon
ça ne favorise peut-être pas la
lisibilité du système mais finalement ça
permet quand même d'attraper un certain
nombre de ménages et d'accompagner
peut-être de manière plus efficace
encore
à ce jour les les
gens qui ont cette préoccupation et qui
se demandent comment passer à l'acte de
la rénovation énergétique de leur
bâtiment mais je ne sais pas si le
guichet unique était sur l'outil d'aide
ou si c'était sur l'accompagnement
on est sur des politiques qui
procèdent d'engagement internationaux
qui procède de grands engagements
nationaux celui de la neutralité carbone
à l'horizon 2050 donc c'est par
définition forcément si peut-être une
question sur la décentralisation
possible de de cette politique
autant il y a des sujets qui
certainement pourraient pour être
décentralisé en un bloc avec à la fois
l'attribution un niveau de
responsabilité de un niveau de
compétence plutôt
alors soit communal département région
mais donner à la fois les
responsabilités les moyens parce que
c'est ça des centralisé c'est de donner
la responsabilité
et les moyens quand on fait si on fait
que l'un ou l'autre ça généralement ça
fonctionne pas bien mais mais là en
l'occurrence
paraît difficile d'attribuer à un niveau
de collectivité
la responsabilité d'une politique comme
celle-là sur laquelle l'État c'est
lui-même engagé donc je crois que on
doit garder cela
énergétique une très forte implication
de l'État mais aussi de ménager
aux collectivités qui sont parfois en
charge de politique voisine je pense à
la politique logement
des moyens de s'articuler avec cette
grande politique d'État qui est celle de
la rénovation énergétique donc il y a je
crois sur un sujet comme celui-là
matière plutôt à faire de la
coordination des différents niveaux de
collectivité plutôt qu'à de manière pas
du tout simpliste parce que ça peut être
parfois très efficace mais à attribuer
la responsabilité à un seul et même
niveau d'administration
la perception que j'aime par exemple
cette fois-ci plus comme comme mère
c'est que la politique du logement par
bassin de vie envisageable je sais pas
si du tout si c'est
des réflexions qui encourt mais
théoriquement visage de dire voilà sur
un bassin de vie tel niveau de
collectivité à la responsabilité de
loger les habitants qui s'y trouvent
pourvu qu'ils aient aussi la capacité de
construire attribuer les logements enfin
donc une vraie décentralisation et les
responsabilités et les moyens mais
la rénovation énergétique elle procède
d'un engagement qui
en 2050 est impérieux impératif donc je
crois se prête pas bien à être délégué
ou décentralisé à un autre niveau
d'administration que celui de l'État
même s'il est encore très partisan de la
collaboration des différents niveaux sur
sur ce sujet
est-ce que
nous avons travaillé effectivement sur
le le financement de la rénovation en
2022 là c'est une étude avec des des
aides sur le logement individuel dans la
fiction sur les financement dans le
logement individuel et les copropriétés
je donnerai peut-être la parole à José
pour préciser cet aspect et sur
effectivement les la façon dont on
pourrait utiliser ces réflexions enfin
où ça se travaille qui a été fait sur le
financement pour essayer de prolonger
tout à l'heure que sur le sur le
financement je crois pas qu'on soit
encore au bout du chemin et que même les
concepts à forger me semble
encore
devant nous même si on a quelque chose
qui sur le plan strictement économique
d'un peu étonnant puisqu'on a des
investissements
qu'on connaît donc on sait à peu près
cerner les modalités de réalisation on
sait à peu près quelle est aussi leur
rentabilité puisqu'on on est capable de
voir la baisse des consommations
énergétiques dans le temps et donc on a
des investissements rentables qui ont du
mal à se réaliser et donc je crois que
c'est une c'est un petit défi qui nous
est lancé collectivement de comprendre
pourquoi ce type d'investissement même
s'ils sont sur des durées parfois un
petit peu longues on est sur 20-30 ans
malgré tout on n'est pas non plus sur
malgré la hausse des prix de l'énergie
sur des sur des investissements qui est
une rentabilité immédiate néanmoins ils
ont une rentabilité et pour autant donc
on n'arrive pas aujourd'hui dans notre
système de financement arriver à agreer
facilement des prêts autour de cette
rénovation donc
on a à mon avis un travail à continuer à
conduire avec les institutions de
financement et qui a place avec la place
bancaire et je sais d'ailleurs ce
travail à court la FBF travail sur ce
sujet et comme prévu de aussi de se
rencontrer avec eux parce que c'est un
petit peu
une faille de marché mais pas loin des
investissements rentables qui ne se
financent pas ça n'existe normalement
pas dans une économie de marché ou les
moyens les financements vont vers les
investissements qui produisent une
rentabilité
j'ai pas José si tu voulais sur le parti
peut-être sur le sur la question du
financement
juste évoquer un point
par comparaison qui est celui pour
approfondir un petit peu la question de
garantie de performance c'est-à-dire et
faire un parallèle avec ce qui s'est
passé sur la maison individuelle au
début des années 90 je crois quand a été
mis au point le contrat de construction
de maison individuelle qui garantissait
à l'acheteur un délai une qualité et un
prix
et l'idée c'est de transposer cette
cette façon de faire à la rénovation
alors c'est plus compliqué puisque il y
a déjà un bâtiment existant et il faut
garantir des choses en plus et il faut
être capable il faudrait être capable en
plus de garantir un résultat énergétique
qui permet de maîtriser la consommation
et dire que alors effectivement on s'est
évoqué dans nos différentes études
pardon
excusez-moi
est-ce qu'il faut que je reprenne ou
vous avez à peu près entendu le début
et donc dans le cadre de France 2030
donc la dame en tant qu'opérateur de
France 2030 va lancer prochainement un
appel à projet pour aller chercher
justement des solutions de ce type là
c'est-à-dire auprès de groupements dans
lesquels on trouvera des concepteurs des
des
réalisateurs de travaux donc des
entreprises des financeurs des assureurs
donc investisseurs banquier etc donc
c'est très ouvert pour que
cette initiative qu'on se permet de
constituer donc des groupements qui
fassent
finalement ensemblier opérateur en
sanglier c'est le terme et qui soit
capable de garantir finalement
[Musique]
un prix une qualité un délai un résultat
énergétique de garantir aussi le risque
de défaillance financière du maître
d'ouvrage bref un paquet complet pour
aller chercher des situations où on fait
des rénovations globales avec garantie
de résultats et donc un financement
crédible sur la durée sur la durée de
l'investissement
voilà donc ça va être lancé
prochainement donc on espère pouvoir
trouver un certain nombre de groupements
issus de cet appel à projet qui nous
permettra justement de d'expérimenter
tester voir un petit peu ce qui est
faisable ce qui bloque quelles sont les
points sur lesquels il faut il faut
insister et on va accompagner ça d'une
étude
visant à dimensionner à concevoir la
dimensionner un fonds de garantie pour
accompagner ces opérateurs enseignés en
cas de en cas de défaillance encore une
fois du de leur part pour avoir un
système complet pour aller chercher ce
type de contrat
voilà donc après évidemment il faudra un
petit peu de temps pour que ces
expérimentations se montent se
développent puisqu'on veut qu'elle se
fasse sur des opérations réelles bien
entendu et donc pouvoir aller après au
résultat et en tirer les les
enseignements pour pouvoir développer
des solutions des dispositifs
généralisés éventuellement
actionner la réglementation etc etc
des montages des choses qui existent
dans d'autres pays aujourd'hui
pas à ma connaissance je suis pas sûr
qu'en effet un benchmark
monde entier mais a priori je peux pas
prendre notre connaissance
d'accord monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Directeur
peut-être pour rebondir juste sur ce que
vous venez de je mets de dire
sur la question du de la Société de Tir
investissement et qu'on retrouve dans le
rapport de la dame de 2022
la différence avec ce que propose France
stratégie parce que c'est vrai stratégie
nous a proposé à nous a présenté un
système qui se qui s'apparente en fin de
compte à la fois avec un sanglier et
puis de la même manière un fond de
garantie et pour le coup un
remboursement sur
les éventuels fondament les économies
d'énergie qui pourraient ceux qui
pourraient se faire quelle est est-ce
que c'est facile la même chose ou du
coup c'est c'est une autre non je pense
que c'est la même chose alors peut-être
donc là on pourra regarder plus
précisément et vous répondre par écrit
si vous voulez vraiment des nuances et
des précisions
peut-être que dans les modalités de mise
en oeuvre il y a des différences je sais
pas mais c'est bien le concept en fait
il faut attirer des investissements
privés évidemment pour les attirer il
faut qu'ils aient des garanties et donc
ça ça c'est finalement des garanties à
tous les étages encore une fois le prix
de la qualité le délai etc et donc il
faut arriver à mettre en place ces
garanties et à les assurer
mais on pourra revenir plus précisément
sur le détail de l'analyse avec le même
principe
nationale on a auditionné madame wargon
les semaines précédentes et c'est vrai
qu'elle nous faisait pas des difficultés
qui pouvaient y avoir de coordination en
fait de lien entre Lana et la dame et
notamment dans le domaine de la
rénovation d'innovation énergétique et
donc le savoir du coup en fait si vous
aviez le même ressentiment en tout cas
de problématique ou de liens entre ces
deux ces deux structures on a auditionné
la nage juste avant
et où est-ce que aussi ça évolué et
est-ce que où est-ce qu'on en est
aujourd'hui
et puis pareil
wargon a évoqué la décision de confier
le pilotage de France Renov à la nappe
pour justement limiter l'éclatement de
la politique de rénovation énergétique
de la même manière que vous français et
du coup la place la place de l'ADEME sur
ce sur ce sujet
également on a on a auditionné dans les
semaines dernière l'Observatoire
national de la rénovation énergétique
c'est vrai que c'est un outil en tout
cas qui était voulu pour le fait en tout
cas d'avoir
une visibilité et d'avoir des chiffres
enfin et voir cette évolution
je sais que vous participez à la
gouvernance et savoir un petit peu
quatre ans après sa création ce que vous
ce que vous en retirez en tout cas sur
cette sur cet outil
voilà est-ce que ça a permis vraiment
d'avoir des des éléments suffisamment
suffisamment fiables donc on a eu aussi
également une présentation de leur
différents chiffres c'est qu'on voit
qu'on a évidemment pas beaucoup de recul
puisque 2019 mais voilà voir votre votre
retour par rapport à ça
vous avez beaucoup du coup parlé de
justement de rénovation globale et donc
plutôt d'aller sur le sur le BBC c'est
vrai que c'est
une des questions dont on se pose et de
savoir toujours enfin voilà on veut tous
aller vers une rénovation qui soit le la
plus complète possible
comment vous voyez du coup les choses
parce que c'est vrai que on a eu
plusieurs plusieurs retours entre
certains qui nous disent
c'est la rénovation globale ou rien quoi
il faut vraiment aller vers cette vers
ce choix là et puis d'autres qui disent
ben il faut il faut quand même garder la
rénovation par geste parce que c'est une
porte d'entrée parce que ça permet de
pouvoir ensuite
multiplier justement les gestes et
notamment quand il y a un accompagnement
efficace peut-être de le faire en
plusieurs temps enfin bon en tout cas il
y a ces réflexions là et c'est vrai
qu'ils peuvent être dans les deux cas
c'est vrai que la rénovation par geste
peut faire aussi que bah on fait qu'un
geste et puis qu'en fait on a très peu
on est très peu intervenus et qu'on a
résultats qui est pas qui est pas
satisfaisant donc avoir votre votre avis
aussi et puis pour terminer peut-être
sur la question des filières vous en
avez un petit peu parlé
donc à la fois la filière du bâtiment
dont on sait qu'il faut et que si on
monte vraiment en capacité de rénovation
on va avoir besoin évidemment de
formation de compétences donc ça c'est
une première problématique et puis
ensuite sur les filières en termes de
matériaux vous en avez parlé aussi par
exemple sur la question du biosourcer
voilà savoir si la dame avait des
réflexions en fait avaient des travaux
sur ce sujet là en tout cas une
visibilité sur ce qui peut se passer sur
les territoires parce que c'est vrai que
ça peut avoir un intérêt en termes de
production de de matériaux au niveau au
niveau local et en lien aussi toute la
problématique de norme qui peut avoir
sur cette sur cet aspect là et sur ces
nouveaux matériaux qui ne sont pas aussi
nouveaux que ça mais en tout cas sur le
fait qu'il puisse rentrer dans une
démarche classique de rénovation
thermique avec
un avis technique avec des assurances
etc et souvent on peut buter par rapport
à par rapport à ça donc voir si du coup
la dame avait aussi une réflexion sur
cette sur ce sujet là merci
alors
effectivement sur le l'articulation Adem
Anna
on a en fait de deux agences qui
historiquement étaient sur des
politiques publiques
sers voisines mais à l'époque assez
différente Lana
historiquement son rôle avait été centré
sur l'amélioration finalement de la
lutte contre l'insalubrité dans le
logement l'amélioration qualitative du
logement et l'ADEME a effectivement
d'existence maintenant mais tu es plutôt
sur les politiques environnementales et
donc ça n'est que depuis quelques années
finalement l'échelle de ces de
la période récente que que qu'on se
trouve à intervenir et à avoir eu le
besoin de s'articuler plus précisément
sur sur une problématique qui est
devenue commune et puis il y a eu
effectivement la décision de de faire
porter France Renov par Lana ça
effectivement ça mettait
nécessiter effectivement de pouvoir bien
articuler ce que je veux dire c'est que
c'est pas
illogique que deux agences qui sont dans
des au départ dans des politiques
différentes et le besoin à un moment ou
un autre de d'articuler leur coopération
là la décision de donner France rénov à
Alana et demander à l'ADEME qui avait
commencé à travailler sur le service
d'aide à la rénovation énergétique de le
transférer et à la norme semble des
décisions cohérentes et qui visent
justement à éviter qu'on ne fasse les
uns une partie de la politique et les
autres l'autre morceau donc on a je
crois
on met en oeuvre cette cette décision
qui vise à clarifier le champ
d'intervention des uns et des autres et
alors je sais qu'on a on a parfois c'est
pas autre propos ou sur le rapporteur
mais mais ça nous est arrivé d'entendre
effectivement de travailler sur des
sujets voisins donc on va vous fusionner
alors si on poursuit la logique on
travaille ensemble avec Lana sur la
rénovation énergétique on fusionne avec
Lana on travaille ensemble avec le
stéréa sur l'ingénierie des
collectivités donc fusionne avec le
serema on travaille sur la question des
sols la réhabilitation des sols et leur
valorisation donc il faut fusionner
aussi avec le BRGM au bout d'un moment
quand même de commencer par faire
quelque chose qui sera je crois plus
lisible on est sur des politiques qui
peuvent continuer à être un peu
différentes la NAT continue à avoir
aussi une action sur le sur le logement
et et en revanche il semble qu'on a un
partage des rôles là qui est aujourd'hui
qui a été mis en place avec avec cette
agence sur la rénovation énergétique
qu'il nous faut mettre en oeuvre et
continuer à
finalement à opérer ce partage il est
semble-t-il clair pertinent maintenant
chacun de de trouver ces marques on
continuera à nous à accompagner les
collectivités dans une réflexion plus
globale sur
mais mais
Lana dans l'accompagnement des ménages a
vraiment aujourd'hui un métier et quel
est le seul à réaliser et là seul aurait
à réaliser et ça dépend ça n'est pas
notre rôle à nous je crois que la
doctrine qui prévaut à l'agence à
l'ADEME c'était de dire Lana est sur la
compagnement des ménages et
à la dame on est sur le bâtiment en nous
et sur le fait que de manière finalement
plus long terme les bâtiments et
évoluent et soient prises en des
politiques cohérentes permettant
d'atteindre notamment la neutralité
carbone je crois qu'il voulait
intervenir sur le sur ce point-là
cette question Anna Adem alors j'allais
dire c'est un classique de la
bibliographie quasiment non plus
sérieusement le sujet c'est comment dans
les politiques publiques de rénovation
des bâtiments on rapproche la branche
énergie climat et la branche habitat
logement et ça ça concerne tout le monde
ça concerne d'abord les ministères il
une question de géographique
ministérielle donc on a une une
législature dans laquelle les deux les
deux les deux branches étaient
rapprochés ça concerne les
administrations ça concerne les agences
d'État ça concerne les collectivités
aussi c'est classique dans les
collectivités vous avez la branche
énergie climat environnement et puis la
branche logement bref donc ça ça
concerne vraiment tout le monde
et donc évidemment il faut travailler
ensemble
il y a des questions de d'arbitrage
entre est-ce qu'on fait plus de
d'énergie climat plus d'habitat
logements etc c'est des curseurs à
positionner mais évidemment tout le
monde est doit faire cette cette
jonction
peut-être dire également que quand la
décision a été prise
la dame était tout à fait consentante
c'est à dire qu'on partageait l'analyse
de de du besoin de simplification de
clarification c'est quand même une
politique extrêmement complexe avec
beaucoup d'intervenants et donc le
besoin d'une plus grande lisibilité
et dans la répartition finalement une
manière effectivement comme vient de le
dire Boris Ravignon de de simplifier la
vision d'ensemble Lana en charge le
parcours des ménages dans la rénovation
et l'ADEME plutôt en charge le parcours
du bâtiment c'est à dire que notre
vision c'est 2050 comment on fait pour
que ces bâtiments arrivent à la au
niveau BBC et Lana est entièrement
consacrée au parcours de du de
l'habitant au parcours du ménage qui est
un sujet très compliqué qui doit être un
point d'entrée majeur vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure la question du guichet
unique pas forcément la question du
guichet unique la question c'est le
parcours des ménages c'est comment on
fait comment on va chercher les ménages
comment on les accompagne comment on les
informe on les conseille on les
accompagne pour qui mène à bien leurs
projets qui est un projet avec une
composante énergétique mais pas
seulement évidemment c'est des gens qui
ont un logement qui ont un parcours de
vie qui peut avoir un handicap qui
peuvent vieillir etc etc tout ça il faut
intégrer et le fait que cet ensemble
problématique soit intégrées dans un
seul service public piloté par Lana avec
cette préoccupation du parcours du
ménage ça nous va très bien et on y
contribue et donc on travaille avec Lana
depuis lors tout à fait tout à fait de
manière constructive et on en a pour
l'éternité j'adhisme parce que on va
contribuer à ce service public pour
fournir à Lana des tas d'éléments sur
l'expertise sur la technique
etc et actuellement notre chantier
commun c'est effectivement le co-portage
du programme SAR donc qui va être qui va
être prolongé
donc voilà puisqu'il y a des relais de
financement à trouver donc on travaille
évidemment étroitement la main dans la
main pour
pour cette configuration
je poursuis sur le la question qui
portait sur l'onre l'Observatoire
national de la rénovation énergétique
alors là encore c'est
je crois qu'il était ça a été utile de
le créer cette observatoire parce que on
est sur des politiques qui étaient
parfois à cheval sur plusieurs
ministères qui implique des acteurs
publics mais aussi un certain nombre
d'acteurs privés qui concerne beaucoup
de collectivités territoriales et
différents niveaux et donc le fait
d'essayer de forger des données
réconciliées entre tous ces acteurs là
qui donne une idée de où nous en sommes
de la rénovation énergétique de ce qui
est de ce qu'il y a à faire du travail
et de ce que de ce qui est produit et
pas simplement en données agrégé au
niveau national mais mais aussi au
niveau territorial ça je crois
impliquait et ça exigeait effectivement
qu'il y ait cette démarche
d'observatoire comme ça vu le jour on y
participe nous et on est très heureux de
le faire c'est un peu le même modèle
finalement que que ce que de ce que nous
faisons avec l'Observatoire national de
la précarité énergétique qui existe
aussi sur ce problématique
naturellement avec un angle un peu
différent mais où avec l'ensemble des
organismes publics privés d'importance
et les collectivités on essaie
effectivement donc de
donner des statistiques qui permettent
ensuite
de concevoir les politiques publiques
donc je on est très très positif nous
sur le fonctionnement de cette onre et
on y participe avec meilleur bonne
volonté en apportant sur les éléments
dont on dispose sur la rénovation
globale vous avez raison tout à l'heure
je suis peut-être allé un peu vite parce
qu'effectivement
qu'on soit bien que faire tout le temps
et tout de suite la Réno globale
peut-être peut-être compliqué alors
les réflexions là encore le contrôle du
directeur des villes et territoires
durable mais on est on exclut pas qu'il
puisse y avoir plusieurs gestes ou
plusieurs étapes
mais quand même on se dit qu'il faut pas
qu'il y en ait trop et que en
l'occurrence ces deux ou trois étapes
maximum
et donc donc l'idée c'est quand même que
on est on arrive quand même assez
rapidement à pouvoir les combiner sans
quoi on va dépenser pas mal d'argent
pour un résultat qui risque d'être assez
disceptif pour le pour le ménage José
peut-être pour compliquer pour compléter
pardon alors d'abord se dire que la
rénovation énergétique ça n'est pas
simple alors il y a un certain écart
entre la vision qu'on a la plupart du
public c'est-à-dire bon c'est des
maisons c'est des appartements dans
lesquelles on vit c'est du concret les
relations avec des entreprises c'est
fréquent donc voilà
en réalité la rénovation une rénovation
performante c'est quand même assez
compliqué il y a de la physique
dans dans le sujet
la physique d'une enveloppe c'est un
c'est une science assez compliqué il y a
des choses qu'on a trouvé il y a pas
très longtemps il y a encore des
problèmes de recherche il y a des
matériaux qu'on maîtrise pas très bien
je pense qu'il y a assez peu
d'entreprises qui maîtrisent la cette
question de la migration de la vapeur
d'eau dans une paroi il faut des bureaux
d'études bon bref donc je veux dire ça
n'est pas si simple que ça en a l'air
donc c'est un grand endroit qui mérite
des investigations la démant fait on en
a fait récemment et donc ça a permis de
mettre en évidence de manière concrète
cette question d'enchaînement des gestes
qui sont pas efficaces alors ça peut
s'illustrer alors c'est plus facile ce
serait plus facile avec des schémas mais
très très concrètement par exemple si
vous commencez par changer les fenêtres
avec des fenêtres qui traditionnellement
sont positionnées à l'intérieur du mur
vous changez la fenêtre vous la mettez
au même endroit et puis après vous
voulez faire l'isolation par l'extérieur
à l'isolation elle va être à l'extérieur
du mur la fenêtre est à l'intérieur
entre les deux qu'est-ce que vous faites
bah si vous isolez vous encombrez la
fenêtre si vous isolez pas ça fait un
pont thermique et donc le jour où vous
faites l'isolation par l'extérieur soit
vous enlevez les fenêtres vous en mettez
des nouvelles positionner au niveau de
l'isolation et vous le faites pas et
donc voilà
c'est donc c'est la question des
interfaces c'est à dire c'est un geste
en lui-même il se critique pas par
contre l'interface entre les gestes bah
ça marche ou ça marche pas et si on n'y
a pas pensé avant la plupart du temps ça
ne marche pas entre l'isolation d'un
toit l'isolation d'un mur entre le
dimensionnement de la chaudière et puis
l'isolation etc
on a la dame à publier une quelque chose
comme 70 fiches pour traiter les
interfaces alors il y a des interfaces
matérielles et puis des interfaces
plutôt conceptuel c'est
c'est à regarder soigneusement et donc
pour aller un petit peu aux conclusions
on a conclu en gros que au-delà de trois
gestes trois étapes plus exactement on
peut faire une rénovation par étape
mais au-delà de trois étapes on est à
peu près sûr de pas y arriver quatre à
la rigueur ça peut se discuter dans des
conditions extrêmement précises mais
autant dire que non
et donc on peut faire des étapes à
condition que dans ces étapes on ait eu
la vision d'ensemble dès le début pour
faire les les gestes qui vont constituer
ces étapes dans le bon ordre un truc qui
marche pas par exemple si vous faites
une isolation performante de votre
enveloppe et puis vous dites que la
ventilation vous l'a faite à l'étape
suivante ça veut dire pendant toute
cette étape là vous aurez un appartement
ou une maison qui sera pas ventilé et
donc humidité pathologies aussi bien
pour les habitants que pour le logement
voilà donc
trois étapes maximum
et des étapes bien conçues au départ et
enchaîné
voilà c'est les conclusions alors
effectivement on a c'est assez récent
encore une fois ces connaissances là
elles sont pas si patientes donc ça
c'est la vision technique et donc après
comment on transforme cette vision
technique en politique opérationnelle
comment le finance comment on
l'accompagne comment on met en face des
compétences du côté des professionnels
pour il y a du chemin à faire évidemment
parce que c'est vrai que tout à l'heure
avec avec la nage je trouve qu'on avait
pour le coup pas tout à fait le même
discours quoi qui était un discours
quand même plus
plus modéré en se disant que une
rénovation sur un seul geste bon moi ça
pouvait quand même être voilà c'était
mieux que rien et moins avec justement
cette vision de globale et de se dire il
faut qu'on ait cet accompagnement global
et puis après oui il peut y avoir une
deux trois étapes trois étapes ça me
paraît déjà même compliqué mais bon
mais je trouvais enfin du coup là il y
avait
une orientation un peu un peu différente
et du coup savoir si là actuellement
avec les politiques qui sont mises en
place que ce soit avec ma prime rénov
que ce soit avec la compagnateur Renov
est-ce que du coup vous pensez que le
dispositif il est bien calibré il va
dans ce sens là quoi dans votre sens de
dire on a cet accompagnateur qui est
vraiment là pour pour le coup pour
accompagner sur la sur la globalité et
puis ensuite voilà de permettre à ce que
tout ce que dit se passe se passe pas ou
en tout cas se passe bien et qu'on est
ces différentes étapes qui se qui se
déroulent correctement
comme je disais bon la technique suffit
pas pour avoir un dispositif de
politique publique et qui fonctionne
voilà
je crois que ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que encore une fois c'est cette prise de
conscience elle est récente notre
sentiment c'est qu'elle elle est de plus
en plus présente dans l'esprit des
acteurs donc il y a pas de doute
là-dessus que depuis quelques années ces
dernières années donc cette question de
rénovation globale rénovation
performante c'est devenu un vrai sujet
ça n'était pas avant
et donc la question c'est comment on
passe progressivement ça sera forcément
progressif on peut pas on voit bien
quand il y a des modifications des
politiques des aides à quel point ça
peut bouleverser la filière etc donc ça
ne peut se faire que progressivement
le chantier est ouvert donc la façon
dont ma prime rénove évoluera pour aller
vers plus de rénovation globale le
chantier est ouvert donc évidemment la
DM va y contribuer
voilà donc je pense que
la prise de conscience est là et le et
les choses vont évoluer c'est pas simple
après donc il y aura forcément des
exceptions en pensant en particulier au
public les plus modestes donc il y a
évidemment des
urgences sur des urgences des priorités
qu'il faudra qu'il faudra gérer voilà
c'est toute cette toute cette complexité
et cette ces évolutions qu'il faut
pouvoir mettre en œuvre
les questions autour de la filière la
structuration de la filière et là on a
on a effectivement une mission de
formation de des professionnels certains
initiatives prises pour permettre
alors la formation la plus large
possible mais c'est les travail à
accomplir et est immense sur sur ce
sujet et et puis sur la partie matériaux
nouveau là on a des appels à projets qui
permettent aussi d'améliorer
José de te laisser compléter mais qui
permettent d'améliorer de sélectionner
pas seulement des matériaux en tant que
tel mais mais surtout des matériaux des
conditions de mise en œuvre
oui donc là et c'est tout toute la
fonction soutien à l'innovation de
l'ADEME qui se déploie dans ce dans ce
champ des matériaux des filières donc
les matériaux bois et biosourcés les
matériaux les combinaisons de matériaux
donc il y avait il y a pas très
longtemps un appel à projet mixité donc
pour idée finalement d'utiliser chaque
matériau dans le meilleur de lui-même
avec des combinaisons donc qui qui sont
optimisés
pour revenir sur les biosourcés donc il
y a beaucoup de travaux évidemment sur
le bois sur les autres matériaux le
chanvre le lin etc très concrètement par
exemple donc l'ADEME soutien la
structuration des filières donc on peut
avoir des accords cadres avec les
organismes professionnels pour soutenir
le déploiement de ces filières
biosourcés
la normalisation par contre c'est plutôt
le CSTB qui
on peut y contribuer en soutenant par
exemple le développement des ce qu'on
appelle les FDES donc les fiches
déclaratives environnement et
environnementales sanitaire des
matériaux c'est-à-dire quand un nouveau
matériau est mis sur le marché il doit
dire qu'est-ce qu'il a sous le capot en
quelque sorte donc ça coûte un peu
d'argent évidemment pour le promoteur de
ce matériau et donc la dame cofinance
cette
la réalisation de ces fiches qui leur
permet après d'être dans les moteurs de
calcul etc comme les autres matériaux au
même titre que les autres matériaux
classiques voilà oui on soutient c'est
le développement de ces filières qui
sont très ancrées sur les territoires
les territoires étiennes c'est de la
proximité donc c'est du bas carbone
évidemment
la plupart du temps
pas que notre collègue s'abîme Draxler
avait une question à vous poser oui tout
à fait en fait le rapporteur a déjà posé
un certain nombre de questions qui
m'intéressait monsieur le Président le
premier février dernier à l'occasion
d'une table ronde qui était organisée
par la commission culture du Sénat vous
nous disiez qui était important à vos
yeux d'accompagner la transition
écologique du bâti tout en respectant
celui qui a une valeur patrimoniale
historique ou architectural et
aujourd'hui avec la mise en oeuvre du
nouveau DPE l'arrivée du zan on sent
vraiment l'urgence de valider justement
ces matériaux dont on vient de parler
des matériaux respectueux de ce type de
bâtiment de créer des labels nouveaux de
diffuser des règles de bonnes pratiques
pour éviter aussi un saccage patrimonial
et une banalisation ensuite du bâti de
notre pays alors à l'occasion de cette
table ronde où nous disait que la dame
concentrait son travail sur la recherche
dans ce domaine
qu'elle considère que le bâti ancien
dans toute sa diversité n'est pas encore
suffisamment documentée pour toutes les
caractéristiques thermiques
hydrothermiques architectural alors mes
questions sur ces recherches
je fais j'ai regardé un petit peu et
j'ai vu qu'en 2011 déjà il y avait eu un
rapport battant je crois que ça
s'appelle sur la modélisation du
comportement thermique du bâti ancien
d'avant 1948 qui a été demandé par
l'ADEME au cerema et qui a été réalisé
en prolongement d'études qui ont été
déjà réalisés en 2005 entre 2005 et 2007
donc ça fait quand même très très
longtemps qu'on travaille sur ces
particularités alors voilà en fait tout
avant que le rapporteur ne vous pose
question je voulais justement que vous
nous disiez nous en disait plus sur ces
matériaux bio sourcés qui sont
aujourd'hui validés ou en cours de
validation
et sur les possibilités aussi de voir se
développer des filières locales donc
française de production et de
transformation qui pourraient en
découler puis à quelle échéance on peut
espérer les les voir arriver alors il y
a aussi aujourd'hui un problème de coût
qui pousse ses particuliers à tourner
vers des solutions standards qui ne sont
pas adaptées est-ce que vous estimez que
l'on fait suffisamment aujourd'hui en
France pour promouvoir pour soutenir
financièrement accompagner
les filières locales et les particuliers
aussi qui optent pour ce type de produit
et puis voilà pour finir en fait moi
j'ai l'impression que vous écoutant
qu'on découvre encore aujourd'hui qu'on
fonctionne le bâti alors qu'en même
temps on est déjà dans l'injonction
d'isolation notamment pour les
propriétaires bailleurs donc alors
est-ce qu'on n'est pas un peu dans une
situation où les gens vont peut-être
faire des choses sans sans n'étant pas
véritablement inform é des spécificités
de leur bâti notamment de ce bâti
patrimonial voilà
alors je vous confirme effectivement
cette audition
où j'avais entendu votre rapport sur sur
la question m'avait amené à retravailler
ensuite avec avec les équipes parce que
ça va beaucoup inquiété de m'apercevoir
que sur un tiers à peu près puisque le
bâti d'avant 48 c'est à peu près ça
autour de 30 % du du bâti de pays on
avait
de tels inquiétudes et qu'on était à
finalement presque dans une situation où
on risquait d'opposer d'en venir à
opposer la logique de rénovation
énergétique avec tout ce qu'elle
implique y compris d'ailleurs aussi de
l'amélioration des conditions de vie
monétaire sociale de des gens qui vivent
parce que derrière la hausse des prix de
l'énergie risquaient de frapper un
certain nombre des habitants et donc on
opposait la logique rénovation et la
logique conservation du patrimoine donc
j'avais
fait passer le message qu'il y avait des
inquiétudes sur le fait qu'on puisse
avoir que le DPE s'applique bien au
bâti d'avant 48 et qu'il
néglige pas
les spécificités de ce bâti on m'a
confirmé effectivement que un centre de
valeurs standard qui sont qui sont
utilisés qu'on a du mal à apprécier
parce que il y a une très grande
diversité des bâties d'avant 48 qui
parfois posent une vraie difficulté sur
l'évaluation de la performance
énergétique donc je confirme que qu'on a
identifié
et qu'on avait déjà identité depuis un
certain temps vous le rappeliez ce sujet
et on va effectivement s'appliquer à
essayer d'avancer sur cette question je
crois vraiment qu'il y a aussi un sujet
d'animation des de la filière en
l'occurrence sur cet aspect c'est pas à
proprement parler le métier premier de
l'ADEME mais on doit pouvoir trouver sur
ce sujet des alliés pour travailler
localement plus localement
bien sûr l'animation des filières et
donne donner effectivement l'envie
certains nombres collectivités de
d'organismes notamment aux chambres des
métiers de de au fédérations
professionnelles du bâtiment FFB qui a
pub de s'engager justement dans une
démarche de formation de leur de leur
personnel et leurs entrepreneurs sur sur
cette question de rénovation tant dans
le dans le rénovation énergétiques
performantes dans le bâti ancien mais je
vais laisser José revenir sur sur
certains points qui assez technique et
vous apporter peut-être des
éclaircissements complémentaires oui
parce que vous avez cité donc battant
qui est effectivement un projet ancien
il y en a eu d'autres
et donc le problème de maîtrise là on
est comme je disais tout à l'heure la
physique de l'enveloppe la physique de
ces enveloppes là c'est pas tant la
question des matériaux biosourcés donc
la fibre de bois etc donc c'est des
choses qu'on maîtrise bien
c'est plutôt le donc les parois
existantes entre un mur en granit un mur
en tuffeau un mur en pisé un mur en
colombage
s'il est en pierre suivant qu'il a été
maçonné en terre ou maçonné maçonné au
mortier de chaud et évidemment c'est des
choses si les pierres sont grosses ou
les pierres sont petites et donc c'est
une infinie variété donc la modélisation
ça rien à voir avec un béton dont qui
est parfaitement normé à la sortie de la
centrale à béton et donc là il y a une
variété qui fait que effectivement il
faut passer du temps pour aller chercher
ses matériaux les tester etc et finir
par les pouvoirs les modéliser et les
mettre dans un moteur de calcul et ça a
été un problème pour le DPE et donc on
arrive maintenant à force de tous ces
travaux là à travailler sur et donc
l'ADEME anime donc avec le CSTB un
travail collectif qui va aboutir qui
doit aboutir à la création d'un moteur
de calcul thermique unique que ce soit
pour le 9 ou l'ancien
en se disant que la physique la physique
du de l'ancien c'est aussi la physique
du neuf les matériaux sont différents
mais les règles physiques sont les mêmes
donc normalement on devrait pouvoir
avoir un moteur de calcul pour tout le
monde avec des valeurs différentes
évidemment suivant les matériaux donc
c'est un peu le rêve de l'unification
donc on y arrive à force d'efforts
bien entendu pour pouvoir et donc
s'agissant du DPE ou de l'audit pour
voir avoir une unité du finalement du
moteur de calcul qui représente
l'intégration des des lois de la
physique pour pouvoir produire un
résultat que ce soit pour le neuf ou
pour l'ancien
voilà donc il y a encore quelques années
là pour arriver à l'unicité de ce moteur
de calcul cela dit le problème reste
compliqué
fera nécessairement
l'objet de compromis c'est-à-dire que
par exemple prenons une maison
paysanne classique avec des murs de 50
ou 60 cm d'épaisseur en pierre
qui a du cachet donc l'idéal d'un point
de vue physique c'est l'isolation par
l'extérieur là au moins il y a rien qui
sort alors à condition là que
les matériaux d'isolation respirent donc
c'est là que les biosourcés sont
extrêmement utiles parce que les
biosourcés ils respirent donc on peut
faire une isolation par l'extérieur
d'une maison en pierre avec des
matériaux biosourcés bien choisis bien
mis en oeuvre etc sauf que on change
complètement le cachet donc on dit bah
non on peut pas faire ça c'est évident
donc on va isoler par l'intérieur sauf
que si on isole par l'intérieur vous
avez des murs de refend entre la cuisine
et la chambre ils sont aussi 60 cm
d'épaisseur vous allez pas isoler
partout à l'intérieur de la maison y
compris ça donc ça veut dire que bah là
vous avez un pont thermique qui fait 60
cm d'épaisseur et vous y pourrez rien
voilà donc on fera des compromis donc la
poutre de 30 cm de côté qui supporte le
plancher de l'étage et le rentre dans le
mur vous pouvez pas isoler la poutre sur
toute sa longueur dans la cuisine et ben
là vous aurez un pont thermique de 30
par 30 qui va voilà si c'est pas isolé
par l'extérieur donc on sera obligé de
finalement choisir sauf à se dire un
moment donné bah là il fait vraiment
trop chaud l'été c'est pas trop le froid
enfin sauf certaines mais quand ça
deviendra invivable en été on se dit bah
est-ce que finalement il faut pas
sacrifier au moins dans certains cas
l'aspect extérieur pour dire bon on va
essayer de faire quelque chose de sympa
mais on va être obligé d'isoler par
l'extérieur parce que on a un vrai donc
c'est des sujets qui sont qui sont pas
très simples il y a pas il y aura pas de
solution miracle en tout cas je dirais
les techniciens les scientifiques on
fait quand même pas mal de progrès pour
mieux appréhender ces questions de
l'isolation du fin de la de la
rénovation du bâti ancien
sauf erreur de ma part José mais on voit
aussi
en poussant les dpets en les rendant
justement on les ancrants encore
davantage parce qu'il y aura pas de
valeur par défaut mais mais du coup une
appréciation vraiment des performances
de chaque type de matériaux on va
pouvoir peut-être aussi rendre un peu
justice à certains modes constructifs
d'avant 48 pour montrer qu'ils ont soit
en été une vraie protection thermique en
permettant de la fraîcheur comme voilà
peu de bâtiments modernes le font et à
l'inverse une inertie au thermique qui
profite aussi à l'hiver et donc c'est ça
c'est ça qui joue là c'est cette de
reconnaître aussi que et d'apprécier
précisément le travail qui resterait à
faire pour atteindre les meilleurs
objectifs parce que
en droit de penser qu'un bel immeuble
haussmannien vu la qualité des matériaux
qui ont été mis en or il a quand même
certaines qualités thermiques que
beaucoup beaucoup de bâtiments plus
récents n'ont pas et n'auront jamais
ou pas encore avant rénovation en tout
cas
est-ce que vous avez encore une question
ou deux
une précision par rapport justement à ce
qui vient d'être ce qui vient d'être dit
notamment sur le confort confort
thermique d'été parce que c'est un sujet
pour le coup qu'on aborde pas souvent et
pourtant si on regarde les projections
on sait que les épisodes à 52 degrés en
ville ça va arriver quoi enfin c'est
déjà arrivé puis ça va ça va se
reproduire et donc du coup cette
question là elle devient hyper
importante
en fait justement dans le DPE je sais
pas s'il y a vraiment des
détails en tout cas sur la question
justement de des performances thermiques
d'été
parce que c'est vrai que suivant les
techniques qu'on va mettre en place que
ça soit en isolation en comble en
toiture ou que ce soit en façade on n'a
pas du tout les mêmes résultats
finalement on peut avoir des résultats
très bons pour un confort thermique
d'hiver et être très moyen sur sur l'été
et notamment sur la question d'inertie
des phasage etc
donc ce que ça c'est des choses en tout
cas sur lesquelles vous êtes
attentif en tout cas parce que c'est
vrai que ça en même en termes
énergétique puisque derrière ça veut
dire clim etc donc on a aussi intérêt à
y penser très fortement
alors cette question du confort d'été
donc dans le DPE je crois pas pour
l'instant qui est quelque chose de
concret donc c'est récemment ça a été
récemment introduit dans la
réglementation du neuf donc qui est
encore une fois est plus facile et la
plus facile donc c'est la première étape
par contre je pense qu'effectivement
maintenant chaque fois qu'il y a un
audit qui est fait avec des
préconisations de travaux et en
particulier dans les régions les plus
sensibles évidemment cette question du
confort d'été doit être regardée par le
professionnel donc vous avez parlé du
choix de l'isolant par exemple pour la
toiture et avec la question du déphasage
le choix du type de ventilation etc
mais dans le DPE lui même ça ça n'est
pas un ça n'est pas encore un critère de
notation
écoutez je pense qu'on a fait le tour en
tout cas je vous remercie très
sincèrement pour cette audition qui a
été très intéressante si vous avez des
éléments
complémentaires n'hésitez pas à nous les
faire passer sur le questionnaire ou
d'autres données que nous aurions pu ne
pas évoquer aujourd'hui et je vous
souhaite une bonne fin de journée je
vous remercie d'être venu à cette
audition merci madame le Président merci
monsieur le rapporteur
merci beaucoup et on vous fait donc
passer
la fin de la semaine peut-être
qu'est-ce qui vous convient
ça sera très bien très bien merci
beaucoup
bonne soirée